Well, my favorite passages in scripture is Exodus 6.
Why Exodus 6?
Well, it's not because of Moses, believe it or not.
And it's not because that Moses is
on the brink of the Israelites leaving Egypt
and this really cool escape plan
that Moses is going to lead the nation of Israel on.
No, believe it or not, here's why.
Because we discover something about God
that we did not previously know
from the very beginning of scripture
all the way up to now.
In verse one of chapter six,
the Lord said to Moses,
now you will see what I will do to Pharaoh.
Because of my mighty hand, he will let them go.
Because of my mighty hand,
he will drive them out of his country.
God also said to Moses,
I am the Lord.
I appear to Abraham, to Isaac,
and to Jacob as God Almighty.
But by my name, the Lord,
I did not make myself known to them.
I also established my covenant with them
to give them the land of Canaan
where they lived as aliens.
Moreover, I have heard the groaning of the Israelites
whom the Egyptians are enslaving
and I have remembered my covenant.
I love this passage
because this is where we start to see God
in a different light.
More than just this idea of God Almighty.
So Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob
sort of saw God as God Almighty.
And all that means is
the God that's better than every other God,
the Creator God,
just this sort of person up here.
Now there's some relational stuff going on
with those three,
but not in the same way that we see it with Moses.
He makes the covenant,
but here he remembers the covenant
and the covenant's becoming more of a reality
than it was before.
This is where we start to see
the personal nature of God.
And that is incredibly important
when we start talking about monotheism.
Because we're not just talking about
the fact that a singular God exists.
We're talking about something slightly more than that.
Now, we're talking about naturalism.
We talked about the dominant view of the West.
We talked about pantheism,
the dominant view of the East.
We talked about the conversions of the two
and how they don't work on the buffet.
We talked about all of those things.
Monotheism really is the view
that God has made himself known.
That God has made himself known to us
in a very personal and very real way.
But, so before we need to make a case
for Christianity to be true,
before we go any further, right?
We've talked about what truth is
and logic and faith and apologetics.
We've talked about worldviews
and we've talked about naturalism.
We've talked about pantheism.
Before we go any further,
before we talk about the resurrection
and before we talk about scripture
and before we talk about how God has made himself known,
we need to be able to show
that there is a single, personal, all-powerful creator.
So I wanna make something really clear here.
We're talking about monotheism as a worldview.
So within that worldview,
you have other religions as well.
You have Judaism, you have Christianity,
but you also have Islam.
Now, when we're talking about the buffet
of a bunch of worldviews,
when we're talking about monotheism,
we're talking about, listen,
we're gonna put the buffet aside
and we're gonna order off a menu
and get the actual dish
that we know is the best possible dish
that satisfies us the most,
gives us the proper nutrients.
In other words,
the worldview that is most consistent,
the worldview that is most coherent,
and the worldview that speaks to the reality the best.
Now, we're gonna talk about specifically next week
and moving forward of why Christianity
within the framework of monotheism is true.
And the rest of them will go away.
But for this right now,
we're just talking about monotheism in general.
And we're talking about the idea of a loving, personal God.
Now, when we talked about pantheism,
we talked about the idea of that there's,
that there needs to be some kind of distinction, right?
So, we're gonna take that distinction
and take it one step further
and talk specifically about the idea
of a personal, caring God.
But I could take that even one step further.
If you go back to Exodus six,
you look at what God says.
It says, I am the Lord,
I appeared to Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob as God Almighty.
I appeared to them in one way.
But by myself, by my name, the Lord,
this is again going back to the idea of Yahweh,
I am who I am, the name of God,
the utter holiness of God, the other thanness of God.
God takes who he is a step further in front of Moses
and says, I am more than just God Almighty
over everything else.
I am who I am, Yahweh.
And they kind of describe what that looks like
and we can add into our focus
the idea of a God who redeems.
A God who is not just out there creating things
and leaving it alone.
We're talking about a God
who is actively engaged in history,
redeeming, pursuing his own creation,
that is made in his image.
That he is chasing after us,
even after we screwed it up.
He is chasing us down, drawing us back to him
because of his love for us.
That's pretty profound.
That sets us up for what Jesus does.
That sets us up for belief in the Holy Spirit.
That sets us up for the belief in the Trinity
that gives us a better understanding of who God is
as we move into really what this idea
of monotheism actually looks like.
So we've had you take your students,
especially in small groups
and working through the Bible study in large group
sort of really get a feel for
how naturalism and how pantheism
sort of has infiltrated and influenced our current culture.
I want you to sort of back out of that for a second
and sort of return to tables.
I want you to explore with your students now
how looking at the world through the eyes
of a monotheistic worldview,
how that could actually influence the culture.
Because ultimately as Christians,
we are called to get into our culture
and impact our culture for the gospel.
So what does that look like?
So how then does your worldview change?
So even for your students
who maybe don't see the world
as a monotheistic through a monotheistic worldview
just yet,
encourage them to take a step back
and ask them what would it look like
if I viewed the world that way?
What would it look like if I saw God as one God,
more than one God as a personal God,
more than just a personal God as one who cares
and is actually pursuing me individually?
How would that change your students' lives?
How would that change their thoughts on morality?
How would that change their thoughts on justice?
How would that change their thoughts on love
on their relationships with their friends and their family?
How would it even change how they function at school?
How would their entire lives change
if they thought that way, right?
So have them explore what that looks like
and encourage them to sort of maybe try it out
and see what happens.
And then as we continue to move forward,
we'll be building the case
that within the monotheistic framework,
Christianity represents absolute truth.